lo que comenzó como un amistoso juego de
azar rápidamente se convirtió en un
estratégico referendo constitucional y
muchos argelinos creen que la votación
no llevará a muchos cambios
como de costumbre votarán en mi nombre y
lo han hecho desde 1962 así que déjenos
continuar
he leído la constitución y no me
conviene
cuando nos llaman para votar respondemos
pero después cuando hay problemas los
políticos no se encuentran en ninguna
parte nuestros hijos no tienen trabajo
no hay vivienda no hay nada
el presidente abdel me diste boom afirma
que las reformas constitucionales
propuestas cumplen con las exigencias de
las protestas antigubernamentales del
irak un movimiento que ha visto a miles
de personas salir a las calles pidiendo
el fin de la corrupción las protestas
semanales lograron forzar la salida del
ex presidente abdelaziz buteflika en
2019 después de que se mantuviera en el
poder durante 20 años y para muchos es
el irak lo que está en la papeleta
electoral en este referéndum
todo el mundo debería ir a las urnas
porque hay injusticia en este país esta
constitución es el remedio para todo y
sería bueno que el pueblo votará sí a la
constitución colocar investigar cuando
el presidente de wulff fue elegido el
año pasado solicitó dialogar con el irak
algunos dicen que la constitución
reformada muestra que cumplió su promesa
el texto propone en efecto nuevas
libertades para permitir a los militares
argelinos intervenir en el exterior e
impone límites a la duración de los
mandatos
la constitución sigue dando al
presidente la mayoría de los poderes por
eso para los activistas prodemocracia
que quieren una renovación completa de
la clase política de argelia
estos cambios no bastan